bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
vi dico sono fa vj oggi siamo su def che
sarebbe un videogioco in d oro tra i
migliori in circolazione a quanto pare
siamo al suo play 31 ottobre 2008
l'ispettore and james è a caccia del 6
archivia chiamato lady def
l'ultima vittima dei suoi crimini e sono
trovata in un hotel economico dove lady
jane sta investigando attualmente
sfortunatamente per l'ispettore il
killer è ancora lì continua
mi piace questa trama questo l'hotel
bello va bene io sono l'ispettore e devo
trovare chi ha commesso l'omicidio
andiamo in di horror più bello del
dell'anno quanto detto mazza che buio
permesso
sto cercando una killer
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi spero che la vita vi sia
piaciuto come al solito se vi è piaciuto
lasciando commento è un bel mi piace al
video sono stati city iscrivetevi e noi
come sempre ci deve dire da ragazzi
[Musica]